[Musique]
christoph daum beau bonjour bonjour
merci de participer à ce vip exclusif
exclusivement réservé à la poule du mans
vous êtes le compagnon de jean pierre
coffe et vous avez suivi l'histoire du
début si on peut dire comment ça s'est
passé cette histoire de poules et de la
poule et jean pierre coffe quoi parce
qu'en fait jean pierre coffe était très
ami avec le sénateur maire jean claude
boulard
ouais et il lui parle que il voulait
remettre en place la souche de
l'allemand qui avait disparu et ça a
beaucoup amusé jean pierre le fait de de
réintroduire cette poule qui finalement
sur toutes les grandes tables françaises
depuis rabelais on parle de la poule
l'allemand c'était là le mans et ça
amuse énormément jean-pierre et il a
donné beaucoup de conseils il a il est
allé la voir parce que c'est une souche
qui redémarre donc qui salit faire
renaître
finalement il a fallu faire renaître
cette souche heures et je crois que même
qu'elle a eu les honneurs de l'elysée
alors le en 2015 je crois que c'est m
avril ou mai 2015 quand jean pierre a
reçu des mains du président la
république la légion d'honneur en
comblant françois hollande
le sénateur maire jean claude boulard du
mans est rentré avec la poule
voilà donc à la vue en même temps elle
aussi les honneurs et elle s'est
échappée dans les grands salons des
villes qui étaient attribuées à bank of
l'une des deux poules qui vient de
rentrer aujourd'hui à versailles était
la poule qui devait dans notre jardin
est bon par manque de temps moi je ne
peux pas m'en occuper donc elle est en
fait entre l'élysée versailles les
grands lieux c'est une poudre est
d'accord et vous donc vous êtes toujours
dans votre maison vous organiser des
événements vous avez vous fait vivre le
lieu comment ça se passe je crois qu'il
ya un grand jardin
en fait il a fallu il faut tenir le
domaine oui c'est pas énorme céder ses
deux hectares mais c'est un parc tout ça
c'est un petit arboretum
et bien pour le faire vivre
il ya des vies de jardin j'ai sorti un
livre sur le jardin secret de jean
pierre coffe chez larousse sont sortis
où il va sortir est sorti le 27
septembre
ah oui voilà pour le faire vivre et puis
l'entretenir parce que n'y a plus de
jardiniers c'est moi qui c'est moi qui
m'en occupe maintenant entièrement je
suis une antiquaire et en même temps
j'essaye de faire vivre le côté culturel
à la campagne parce que je me trouvais à
la dre à côté de châteaudun avec des
expositions soit des oeuvres
contemporaines d'extérieur ou des
tableaux dans à l'intérieur merci en
tout cas lors du coup de nous prêter
donner cette poule qui qui a grandi chez
vous des parts alors non elle n'a jamais
connu la maison elle te fait non parce
qu'en fait elle devait arriver un mois
après le décès de jean pierre douce et
gelé et la poule est resté dans la salle
et c'est vers cela nous allons bientôt
rencontrer hockey christophe un grand
merci merci et puis à bientôt à la
maison at à très bientôt avec désirs à
bientôt viendra voir tout ça merci
commencé christophe
[Musique]
e
stéphane bern bonjour bonjour merci
d'être présent pour notre caméra tv 78
ont fait un vip spécial poule du mans et
vous n'êtes pas là par hasard vous avez
un rôle très important aujourd'hui quel
est il
c'est pas un rôle très important c'est
un rôle très important d'être un parent
a mal accueilli par un de la poule du
mans plutôt que cette poule du vent a
fait un long chemin depuis le mans
jusqu'à versailles oui elle est
réintroduite aujourd'hui dans dans le
poulailler de versailles la maison du
jardinier
ce qui est d'un très important parce que
la poule du manque toujours une longue
histoire ici à la table des rois de
france
oui et donc elle revient mais elle avait
disparu et c'est le maire du mans qui
l'a réhabilité une certaine manière avec
le parrainage de jean pierre coffe qui
était un ami et qui était le parrain de
cette poule malheureusement jean pierre
coffe disparu et cette poule
eh bien depuis a été réintroduite est
élevé par deux éleveurs de poules et
aujourd'hui donc mon nom offert une elle
est ici je les jeux les baptisés aliénor
parce que ce serait d'aller chaque fois
au mans pour faire une émission de
l'histoire sur aliénor d'aquitaine vivre
avec lui au mans réelle et elle était au
mans donc
donc je crois que c'est important vous
savez ça fait partie du patrimoine
mondial immatériel sait il n'ya pas que
le patrimoine bâti il ya aussi le
patrimoine gastronomique et le
patrimoine immatériel culturel et la
poule fait partie du patrimoine culturel
oui parce que finalement on la fait
revivre et ont fait revivre cette poule
qui avait une longue histoire vraiment
oui on la retrouve dans les écrits de
rabelais chez jean de la fontaine à lait
à la table de louis 15 on parle de 2,2
chapon de du mans donc vraiment elle
existait et elle avait disparu
c'est formidable on sait parce que ces
ballons on avait on ait préféré d'autres
goûts d'autres d'autres d'autres poules
mais qu'elles ont élevé plus et de
gaulle elle est réhabilitée et je pense
voyez-vous qu'elle va permettre d'être
une ambassadrice du mans aussi forte
aussi importante dans le monde que les
rillettes
est ce que je veux dire alors le maurice
de sa poule derrière et puis le
les 24 heures et les 24h j'avais oublié
merci à vous merci beaucoup merci quan à
l'huissier bonjour un jours merci de
répondre à nos questions pour ce vip
consacré à la poule du mans vous en êtes
le papa si je puis dire oui oui vous me
dumont là on dirait effectivement
racontez moi vous êtes éleveurs
professionnels tout à fait effectivement
ça c'est la suite de l'histoire des
volailles du mans qui continue en fait
elle a malheureusement disparu dans les
années 40-50 etc première tentative de
reconstitution dans les années 90 oui
mais très vite on s'est aperçu que
c'était une histoire qui était avec une
volaille qui était hors du commun
et effectivement c'est ce qui m'a amené
à créer mon élevage professionnelle en
2014 pour valoriser cette volée d'accord
qu'est ce qu'elle en quoi est ce qu'elle
est hors du commun comme vous dites est
bien allé aux documents hors du commun
permet à travers son histoire déjà en
fête puisqu'elle a été véhiculé non
seulement à travers la gastronomie
française elle a fait partie de la de
toute cette histoire de la grande loge
toujours way toujours et est valorisé
par brillat savarin grimod de la
reynière qui sont quand même les grands
gastronomes du xviie siècle
et puis par les cercles littéraires
aussi dans les plaideurs de racine et
bien ce grand auteur on parle la
fontaine aussi qu' on est dans ces
fameux japon il qu'elle ait vraiment
inscrite dans le patrimoine vraiment
être dans les photos qu'elle a disparu
pourquoi est-ce qu'on lui a préféré
d'autres races alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'on allait s'éteindre comme beaucoup
de races anciennes en fait taxées les
poules des vaches ou des cochons ce sont
des races à qui demande à grandir avec
du temps
voilà et à un moment donné dans l'après
guerre on n'a plus le temps il faut
produire en masse en tacles
ouais ça a été plus adapté au modèle de
consommation art de production ppi de
consommation et l'arrière en plus
d'accords et donc parce qu'il faut
combien de temps pour être prête à être
massé vraiment avoir une volaille
vraiment aboutie pour se faire plaisir
faut compter cinq à six mois ce qui est
long en fait ce qui est long parce
qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à produire un
poulet de très bas de gamme
naturellement 6 heures en moins d'un
mois
ah oui ça rien à voir et des poulets
intermédiaire à deux trois quatre mois
mais là on pousse à 5-6 mois d'accord
donc vous vous avez entrepris de faire
de régénérer la rate pas de la faire
revivre de la reconstituer donc vous
avez un élevage à la ferme de la poule
noire
vraiment voilà maintenant cinq six ans
déjà j'entame ma cinquième saison oui
voilà et est ce qu'elle est une partie
qu'il a été au niveau mettons nourriture
est moche des rillettes
c'est pour moi par contre effectivement
elle va déjà elle va avoir un accès à un
parcours herbeux rapidement d'accord je
rapidement que d'autres de manière à ce
qu'elles aient accès aux vers de terre
au four mais etc qui sont des potées
vraiment indispensable pour les
volailles
oui et puis petit à petit effectivement
un mélange céréalier qui est vraiment
spécifique avec notamment l'orge et
sarrazin et c'est gratuit donne son goût
particulier ça qui donne le goût la
texture
ouais mais en fait j'ai rien inventé
c'est à dire que j'ai repris tout
simplement ce qui se faisait autrefois
cieux mais à partir du moment où à la
marque et elle a eu des grandes
références
j'ai volontairement rien voulu changer
ce cas pas été le cas des beaucoup
d'autres volailles malheureusement
d'ailleurs que chaque wilaya c'est
vraiment son identité
alors elle justement parlant d'identité
elle est allée à la plume noire reflets
un petit peu vers une crête frisé tout à
fait ce que c'est qu'une crêpe faisait
alors c'est une crête qui est vraiment
crépus avec plein de petites pointes
dessus d'accord qui se termine avec un
éperon horizontale derrière ça c'est
vraiment représentatifs de la race avec
les oreillons blanc sur le plumage
l'oreille en blanc plumage noir voilà
j'essaie de des beaux des beaux morceaux
oui oui ça lui donne à la fois de
l'élégance aussi de la prestance et donc
en plus d'être une bonne volaille c'est
une belle volée oui c'est très joli et
dites moi
aujourd'hui vous êtes à combien de
spécimens alors alors aujourd'hui je
travaille avec une entre 20 et 30
reproducteurs donc ça c'est ce qui se
tient en effectif sur l'élevage oui mais
pour produire 300 voire 400 volaille
ça va être l'objectif cette année en
tout cas voilà d'accord c'est un produit
de saison c'est à dire que en fait je
vais travailler avec les saisons et les
cycles naturels des oiseaux dont il ya
pas des poulets toute l'année les poules
ça pompe à l'hiver logiquement sur une
triche un peu mais je veux pas tricher
les affaires là les poules commence à
prendre maintenant
les poussins vont éclore le mois
prochain et ce jusqu'au début de l'été
et vont grandir pour fournir les volets
première volaille on va dire fin au
début c'est donc on va pouvoir manger
vous allez livrer à des grands chefs
je serai avec les arguments des chefs à
la fois en sorte oui mais aussi sur
paris les départements voisins
en fait ça y est l'opération de
sauvetage de ce réglage non seulement a
réussi quelque part mais en plus de
regagner les belles tables c'est
vraiment en cours aussi l'acteur a gagné
je suis vraiment convaincu des bravo
c'est une belle histoire
merci donc ce couple là ceux
nouvellement résidents versaillais donc
on leur souhaite d'être poussés au
maximum c'est tout ce qu'on peut leur
souhaiter la salsa très bon terrain je
vous rassure avons envoyé au 4 août et
famille nombreuse il battrait du lac
témoin
merci guen à l'uci à bientôt cet élevage
merci au revoir au revoir
e
jean claude boulard bonjour jour vous
êtes le maire du mans puisque oui jusque
là ça va
jusque là ça va vous êtes venu à
versailles pour accompagner des petits
protégés
la pile du nord donc le maire refusait
le maire de versailles viendra saluer
nos poules
eh bien écoutez nous le ferons pas de
votre de votre office excision sache ce
que j'ai vu qu'ils imaginent et flatté
alors racontez moi un peu cette histoire
du grand du monde tu as commencé que
jean pierre coffe ces gens qui s'écoule
avait disparu oui il a reconstitué
c'était un peu long d'expliquer que oui
mais on y croit et l'élevage des leurs
dont trois des espèces ont été
reconstituées fini avait très bien fait
qu'ils sont armés
elle a été évoquée par racines elles
étaient évoqués par les groupes plus
grands auteurs et donc à une dimension
culturelle les diversions cultive une
dimension de l'histoire et pas que des
merdes
alors tes fans berne conjuguer il est
une mission qui conjuguait le patrimoine
des pierres et parfois ni matériel moi
j'ai une conviction sur le met en scène
des pierres il faut chose vivante
ça c'est une intuition et sa présence
vos messages
c'est vrai que si les bras imaginez
qu'un jour on dise tout versailles a été
réveillé par le cri du coq
oui mais ça va être le cas au pire on
vient voir on s'intéresse alors fait
pour repartir
les courriers qui était fermée depuis
marie antoinette pour on illustre
l'intérêt de la prison à vie vante la
présidence ancien vous lire divine
oui viennent aux morts aussi la voir oui
parce que l'élément une région
extrêmement riche au niveau culturel les
arbres d'une heure de paris ils seront
très bien reçu un célèbre marché
d'ailleurs pas hésité à cobham vivant
amateur qui était le marché préférait
déjà bien vrai joker giro mais on vient
des yvelines pour à la poule sur aux
remarques m'ont reçue bombe écouter le
message est passé merci monsieur le
maire
il
[Musique]